today I'm going to talk about technology
and society the Department of Transport
estimated that last year 35,000 people
died from traffic crashes in the US
alone worldwide 1.2 million people die
every year in traffic accidents if there
was a way we can eliminate 90% of those
accidents would you support it of course
you would this is what driverless car
technology promises to achieve by
eliminating the main source of accidents
human error now picture yourself in a
driverless car in the year 2030 sitting
back and watching this vintage today
Cambridge video all of a sudden the car
experiences mechanical failure and is
unable to stop if the car continues it
will crash into a bunch of pedestrians
crossing the street but the car may
swerve hitting one bystander killing
them to save the pedestrians what should
the car do and who should decide what is
instead the car could swerve into a wall
crashing and killing you the passenger
in order to solve to save those
pedestrians this scenario is inspired by
the trolley problem which was invented
by philosopher as a few decades ago to
think about ethics now the way we think
about this problem matters we may for
example not think about it at all we may
say this scenario is unrealistic
incredibly unlikely or just silly but I
think this criticism misses the point
because it takes the scenario to
literally of course no accident is going
to look like this no accident has two or
three options where everybody dies
somehow
instead the car is going to calculate
something like the probability of
hitting certain group of people
if you swerve one direction versus
another direction you might think
slightly increase the risk to passengers
or other drivers versus pedestrians it's
going to be a more complex calculation
but it's still going to involve
trade-offs and trade-offs often require
ethics we might say then well let's not
worry about this let's wait until
technology is fully ready and 100% safe
suppose that we can indeed eliminate 90%
of those accidents or even 99% in the
next 10 years
what if eliminating the last 1% of
accidents requires 50 more years of
research should we not adopt the
technology that's 60 million people that
in car accidents if we maintain the
current rate so the point is waiting for
full safety is also a choice and it also
involves trade-offs
now people online on social media have
been coming up with all sorts of ways to
not think about this problem so one
person suggested the cartridges swerve
somehow in-between the passengers and
the bystander of course if that's what
the car can do that's what the car
should do we're interested in scenarios
in which this is not possible but my
personal favorite was scenario suggests
ssin by a blogger to have an eject
button in the car that you press just
before the car self discharged
so if we acknowledge that cars will have
to make trade-offs on the road how do we
think about those trade-offs and how do
we decide well maybe we should run a
survey to find out what society wants
because ultimately regulations and the
law are a reflection of societal values
so this is what we did with my
collaborators Jean Francois bon a phone
and Valium Sharif we ran a survey which
will presented people with these types
of scenarios and we gave them two
options inspired by two philosophers
Jeremy Bentham and Immanuel Kant Bentham
says the con should follow utilitarian
ethics it should take the action that
will minimize total harm even if that
action will kill a bystander and even if
that action will kill the passenger
Immanuel Kant says the car should follow
duty-bound principles like thou shalt
not kill so you should not take an
action that explicitly harms a human
being and you should let the car take
its course even if that's going to harm
more people what do you think
then thumb or count here's what we found
most people sizes with Bentham so it
seems that people want guards to be
utilitarian minimize total harm and
that's what we all should all do problem
solved but there is a little catch when
we asked people whether they would
purchase such cards they said absolutely
not they would like to buy cards that
protect them at all costs but they want
everybody else to buy cars with minimize
harm
we've seen this problem before it's
called a social dilemma and to
understand the social dilemma we have to
go a little bit back in history so in
the 1800s English economist William
Foster Lloyd published a pamphlet which
describes the following scenario you
have a group of farmers English farmers
who are sharing a common land for their
sheep to graze now if each farmer brings
a certain number of sheets let's say
three sheep the land will be rejuvenated
the farmers are happy the sheep are
happy everything is good now if one
farmer brings one extra sheep that
farmer will do slightly better and no
one else will be harmed but if every
farmer made that individual irrational
decision the land will be overrun and it
will be depleted to the detriment of all
the farmers and of course to the
detriment of the sheep now we see this
problem in many places in the difficulty
of managing overfishing or in reducing
carbon emissions to mitigate climate
change when it comes to the regulation
of driverless cars the common land now
is basically public safety that's the
common good and the farmers are the
passengers or the car owners who are
choosing to drive to ride in those cars
and by making the individually rational
choice of prioritizing their own safety
they may collectively be diminishing the
common good which is minimizing total
harm it's called the tragedy of the
Commons traditionally but I think in the
case of driverless cars the problem may
be a little bit more insidious because
there is no not necessarily an
individual human being making those
decisions so car manufacturers may
simply program cards that will maximize
safety for their clients and those cars
may learn automatically on their own
that doing so requires slightly increase
for pedestrians so to use the sheet
metaphor it's like we now have electric
sheep that have a mind of their own and
they may go and graze even if the farmer
doesn't know it so this is what we may
call the tragedy of the algorithmic
Commons and it offers new type of
challenges so typically traditionally we
solve these types of social dilemmas
using regulation so either governments
or communities get together and they
decide collectively what kind of outcome
they want and what sort of constraints
on individual behavior they need to
implement and then using monitoring and
enforcement they can make sure that the
public good is preserved so why don't we
just ask regulators to require that all
cars minimise harm after all this is
what people say they want and more
importantly I can be sure that as an
individual if I buy a car that may
sacrifice me in a very rare case I'm not
the only sucker doing that while
everybody else enjoys unconditional
protection
so now survey we did ask people whether
they would support regulation and here's
what we found
first of all people said no to
regulation
and second they said well if you
regulate cars to do this and to minimize
total harm I will not buy those cars so
ironically by regulating cars to
minimize harm we may actually end up
with more harm because people may not
opt into the safer technology even if
it's much safer than human drivers I
don't have the answer the final answer
to this riddle I think as a starting
point we need society to come together
to decide what trade-offs we are
comfortable with and to come up with
ways in which we can enforce those
trade-offs so the starting point my
brilliant students Edmund Awad and Johan
D'Souza built the moral machine website
which generates random scenarios at you
basically a bunch of
random dilemmas in a sequence where you
have to choose what the car should do in
a given scenario and we vary the ages
and even you know the species of the
different victims and we've so far we've
collected over 5 million decisions by
over 1 million people worldwide from the
websites and this is helping us form an
early picture of what trade-offs people
are comfortable with and what matters to
them even across cultures but more
importantly doing this exercise is
helping people recognize the difficulty
of making those choices and that the
regulator's are tasked with impossible
choices and maybe this will help us as a
society understand the terms of
trade-offs that that will be implemented
ultimately in regulation and indeed I
was very happy to hear that the first
set of regulations that came from the
Department of Transport announced last
week included a 15 point checklist for
all car makers to provide and number 14
was ethical consideration how are you
going to deal with them so we also help
people reflect on their own decisions by
giving them summaries of what they what
they chose and I'll give you one example
I'm just going to warn you that this is
not your typical example your typical
user this is the most sacrifice and the
most saved character for this person
some of you may agree with him or her we
don't know but this person also had
seems to slightly prefer passengers over
pedestrian in their in their choices and
it's very happy to punish jaywalking
okay
so let's wrap up we started with the
question let's call it the ethical
dilemma of what the car should do in a
specific scenario swerve or stay but
then we realize that the problem was a
different one it was the problem of how
to get society to agree on and enforce
the trade-off they're comfortable with
it's a social dilemma in the 1940s
Isaac Asimov wrote his famous laws of
robotics the Three Laws of Robotics a
robot may not harm a human being the
robot may not disobey a human being and
the robot may not allow itself to come
to harm in this order of importance but
after 40 years or so and after so many
stories pushing these laws to the limit
Asimov's introduced the zeroth law which
takes precedence above all and it's that
a robot may not harm humanity as a whole
now I don't know what this means in the
context of driverless cars and I need
this specific situation and I don't know
how we can implement it but I think that
by recognizing that the regulation of
driverless cars is not only a
technological problem but also a
societal cooperation problem I hope we
can at least begin to ask the right
questions thank
[Music]